[Music]
[Applause]
he is Lewis rck of the mothership a
former Nfl safety former uh front office
executive with the Eagles and with
Washington he was on the call Monday
night the Titans surprising the Dolphins
and uh he's got the Peach Bowl coming up
that'll be December 30th it's Old Miss
in Penn State thanks for joining us do
you think Bill belich knows that what
his future is going to be in New
England then I would
probably I'd venture to say he does okay
I'd say he him in like after all these
years what is it now 23 years is it 23
Seasons that he's coached up there 24
seasons I would I would hope that they
have the kind of
communication that's ongoing and
continuous that kind of lets him know
that look this is kind of what we're
thinking about and how things are going
to go here at the end of the year and
those are kind of things that just kind
of like to me would would seem like it
would be a natural kind of conversation
that's the kind of respect he deserves
and I think he would want to know that
kind of information especially if Mr
craft Jonathan Craft and the rest of the
gang up there were going to go ahead and
make a
decision and yeah I mean I wouldn't be
shocked by it at all if that if if if
it's actually coming to an end how
attractive do you think he would be for
let's say the Chargers Washington
Carolina anybody else oh he's he's
attracted for everybody especially from
a from a program building standpoint in
terms of philosophically how he
thinks you have to win in the NFL he's
always been a guy who's been a step
ahead as far as schemes strategies
tactics he he knows all that stff he
hasn't lost his fast ball in that way
but there's no
question that some of the some of the
decisions that he's made as far as
player selection
have really burned him man he's really
he's really missed the mark on a couple
of those and see that's going to be
that's going to be it what kind of GM
who do you got who do you got that
you're going to pair with him that's
going to be able to withstand the kind
of uh let's just say pressure a guy like
Bill will put on you because I can just
tell you this it ain't like anything
you've ever seen before as far as being
around somebody like that who is as
demanding as accomplished
it's not it's not for everyone it's just
not but do you think he goes in he wants
to be the GM and the coach if he goes to
another place or would he be willing to
acquest to a GM I I I don't I don't
really know I I would think that he
would still I don't think he would ever
just give it up totally I don't think
he'll ever just be a guy who says hey
you know what I don't want anything to
do with it you just pick the players
I'll coach him but I could see a
situation now like remember Andy used to
have control of everything when he was
in Philadelphia at one time everything
now Tom Heckard worked with him but Andy
had control of everything he became and
he he would probably tell you himself
and I don't want to speak for him but I
know how he has talked about it but he
became someone who became an even better
Coach as far as the details are
concerned when he took a lot of that off
of his plate and he just had someone who
he can trust and right now he's Hit The
Sweet Spot with him and Brett down in KC
so could bill get could bill do that of
course he could but who would that guy
be who would it be that he would trust
in that way what's your level of concern
for the Chiefs
oh it's serious it's it's it's
significant
because look I I
think Andy used to say this all the time
then when we were when we were in Philly
like when we used we used to talk about
player profiles especially at the wide
receiver position and we talk about all
this stuff about shary quickness and
explosiveness and he can do this and
Andy used to say this look man can this
guy catch the ball or not because I'm
seeing some issues okay because he would
say you know what he goes he'd be like
correct me if I'm wrong but isn't the
number one job a receiver has to do is
catch the thing he's to say that all the
time and that worries me for this
football team but how do receivers not
catch a football you know because
honestly some guys just have better hand
eye coordination and natural ability in
game situations to track a ball in the
stadium when someone's coming at him
than other guys do and some I mean you
know how it is there's guys who are
there's people who are practice players
and there's people who are Gamers some
people when you rep and you're talking
about it and there's no pressure they
look like all Americans Hall of Famers
when the lights come on they shrink some
of the guys there don't step up and do
the right things when the lights are the
brightest and that see that's all we're
talking about with KC now it's not about
well are they gonna make it to the
playoffs and they are gonna be no with
in casc it's either Super Bowl or the
season stunk that's all that's that's
all it is so yeah I'm concerned that I'm
concerned for sure okay level of concern
more for Kansas City or Philadelphia
moving forward uh more for Kansas City
really yeah I I I think so and I'll tell
you why
um in the in the NFL the game still is
going to all right so it's going to be
about winning at the line of scrimmage
in the postseason and it's about
explosive plays in the postseason that's
what it's about can you control the line
of scrimmage obviously turnover
differential is always going to be there
can you win at the line of scrimmage can
you create explosives it's just too hard
to go 8 nine 10 12 13 plays all the time
Philly can create explosives because
they have they have dudes who can do
that AJ can do it Devonte can do it
Swift can do it Kenny gainwell can do it
in Phil in in Kansas City Travis can
create explosives but he's a tight end
he's not necessarily that guy who can
flip a game on a 10 and who else they
got that's the issue and when you're
talking about winning at the line of
scrimmage yeah KC's offensive line is
still very good and their defense is one
of the best in the NFL I believe
Philly's pass rush will start to show up
I am concerned about their
secondary but I do think they are still
built enough the right way and Jaylen
Herz will get on the same page with his
offense and Brian Johnson will get it
going to the point where I think they
will still be there in the end it'll be
between obviously it'll be between
Dallas Philly and San Fran in the NFC
the AFC is a little bit tougher of a
road for Casey maybe than it's ever been
simply because they can't flip the game
on its head with one play like they used
to be able to former defensive back now
working for the mothership uh with NFL
college football analysis he's Lewis rck
joining us on the program I'm going to
play something that Cam Newton brought
up on his fourth in one podcast and then
get get your reaction to it elar Jackson
obviously Patrick Mahomes Dak Prescott
bra par like but Brock let's they're not
winning because of him he's not turning
the ball over he's managing the game and
if we were to put that in its own right
as game managers Brock per to a Tong of
aloa jarro go and really Dak Prescott
these are game managers they're they're
not difference makers okay in the start
of that answer he talked about you know
momes Lamar Jackson you know they're
they difference makers and then he got
to game managers with Brock pie Dak
Prescott Jared gof is that a slight was
it meant as a slight of course it's
meant as a slight because you know cam
sounds like somebody
who and I and I like cam I I I like him
every time I got a chance to talk to him
I've liked I like the guy but cam just
sound cam just cam comes off as like
bitter like because he thinks he should
still be playing and you know you've
often heard him talk about the fact that
he's better than a lot of the
quarterbacks that are still playing in
the NFL and sometimes when you have that
kind of feeling like you're you're
opinions and you're the lens through
which you look at these guys becomes a
little bit distorted and jaded and and
you say it in a way that kind of makes
you feel better about where you're at or
rather it kind of makes you it just
makes you feel better for lack of a
better phrase here look you know I
continue to have issues with this whole
game manager versus we this guy wins the
game BS because then look I I played in
an era
where here here are the great
quarterbacks I played against all right
I played against Troy when Dallas was
mowing down everybody in Dallas I played
against Elway when TD was going for 2000
yards and they had mcaffrey and they had
Shannon they had all those dudes I
played against Joe and I played against
Steve Young when they had Jerry Rice
John Taylor Brent Jones Ricky Waters
Roger Craig etc etc you know what what's
interesting I remember being a scout
when when uh Payton had Edan and he had
Marvin Harrison he had Wayne he had
Dallas Clark and I'm sitting there going
look these guys then are now these guys
then and now were considered some of the
greats to ever play the game and they
had Hall of Famers all around them but
we become drunk with this notion that
unless you are throwing the foot unless
you're getting hit in the
face the receivers triple covered the
windows an inch by an inch and you
threaded through a keyhole you're not
Elite you're not that great you're not
if un unless you're throwing it off
balance across your body no look 70
yards in the air on a flatline well that
must you're just benefiting from all the
guys around you and it's it's really Dan
it's become stupid it's become stupid
the way in which we are trying to
individualize the game that we all
know reason why we love it because it's
the greatest team sport ever but we want
we are so enamored with trying to put
people in the levels and tears and
that's why there's always this study
about this is category a quarterback
this is category B it's it's
like it's like um quarterback wins right
like we keep using that stat even though
a quarterback could do everything
possible in a game and if he doesn't
have the ball last and his defense gives
it up in the end it still goes as a loss
for him it's like we pick and choose we
move goalpost so damn much in this
business and we have such weird weird
ways of categorizing Elite versus not
yeah we all know that Brock
is not physically and from a throwing
perspective as talented as Patrick
Mahomes no kidding so
what um you know Joe Montana wasn't as
physically gifted as Steve Young Steve
Young's not as physically gifted even
though Steve Young's a Hall of Famer and
one of my best I love Steve Young to
death he's not as physically gifted as
Lamar Jackson as a runner better throw
Etc see like it's just so it's I I I
hate I absolutely hate these
conversations because right now Brock
pie is right in the crosshairs right
he's right in the crosshairs of
everyone's debates right now concerning
whether or not he should be he should be
considered an mdp because anyone could
do what Brock is doing well also if he
was taken in the top 10 of course we
would look at Brock py differently there
you go and you what does that tell you
the fact that we can sit here and admit
this we're already the fact that we
could admit that that well if he was
taken in the top 10 then I wouldn't be
having this conversation already shows
you that really your opinion right now
really doesn't mean a four-letter
expletive that I won't say it really
doesn't mean anything because you're
already admitting that you're biased
simply because of where he came in yeah
and that right there takes all your
credibility and you can just throw it
out the door I hope the I hope the guy I
swear like I hope he wins the MVP so bad
because there will there'll be about six
to eight months worth of conversation
where people are going to be pissed off
well it's like when the Joker was going
to win three MVPs in a row and I I think
people had a problem because he doesn't
jump high he's exactly there's no
highlights you know a highlight will be
a pass and I and I think that that well
he hadn't won a championship so now he's
won a championship and probably should
have been the MVP last year during the
regular season but you know I don't need
excitement I need and and Joe Montana
was a game manager in in my opinion and
Bart Star was and you know Tom Brady
early in his career yes yes we we get
Cam was not a game manager well that's
part of the problem with Cam he didn't
manage a game if you don't manage a game
then you mismanage a game Patrick
Mahomes manages a game and that means
I'm going to make the right call at the
right time I'm going to make the right
play it doesn't mean you're limited
physically
it's mentally you you're ahead of people
and that's what I think it's not a
negative to me to say you know how to
manage your game every great quarterback
Guru teacher coach whatever if you ask
them give me the two primary factors
that determine greatness in quarterbacks
they don't go off schedule throws and
excitement and whether or not he can
throw the ball 70 yards they don't say
that they say decision making yeah
accuracy that's where they start that's
where they start and everything else
from there obviously you need physical
skills and to be able to pass the
football move yeah of course
decisionmaking in accuracy but for Brock
pie it's like well he's not making
decisions Kyle's just telling him in his
ear what to do he's not actually
throwing the football that's an AI
generated guy out there throwing the
football I mean well what the hell do
you want
you know he's getting penalized for the
things that the great say you have to be
able to do to play the position great I
like you fired up I like you yeah I know
you ready to hit somebody you know you
know I always love these conversations
with you man this is always good stuff
you know what go go drill or lski like
right in the middle of his back don't
even tell him it's coming just like
stick him you know what back in the day
back in the early 90s when we could
actually hit quarterbacks and people
didn't cry I would have loved to did you
ever have a quarterback cry when you hit
him cry no you know what because in our
days they didn't say a word I mean
because they expected it they expected I
mean I can tell you man I can tell you I
can just tell you one quick play we're
playing the Dallas Cowboys in the
preseason once down in Texas stadium old
Texas stadium we had scrimmaged against
them when I was with the Raiders um for
like two or three days in training camp
before that and they kept running these
skinny posts and I wasn't I kept getting
I was late on my break out of the middle
of the field and Ruden kept saying he's
like are you going to ever make a play
on this are you ever going to make a
play on this route you going to make a
play on this route or are you just going
to keep watching them catch
it they ran the same play in the in the
game
then and I saw it coming I saw the
formation I saw I believe it was Jason
Garrett was playing quarterback at the
time and I looked and I said here it
comes I didn't even back up I just made
a Bel line right for the receiver D I
hit him with everything I had like it
was a high shot up in the head all this
stuff nobody said a word like I
literally walk by the guy and look now I
understand why you can't do that now but
the game is totally different it's
totally different now and I get why no
quarterbacks didn't cry then but they
can look everybody can you can't hit a
guy hard right now without the whole
sideline you see everybody going like
this it's crazy man you imagine the old
Raiders the Al Davis Raiders if they
played today guys would be in jail yeah
they they sure would you'd have on the
Comm on on the suspended list you'd have
like 40 guys yeah the Raiders are on the
commissioner's exempt list the entire
team hey that's right great to talk to
you have fun in the Peach Bowl and uh
thanks for joining us of course man
thanks that's Lewis rck of the
Mothership